prima di cominciare la volevo dirvi che
sta per iniziare il made in internet il
tour number two che sarà molto ma molto
più figo ricorre l'anno scorso perché ci
saranno miliardo di cose in più e niente
volevo lasciare in descrizione il link
per le tappe nel caso foste interessati
il 4 febbraio c'è la prima data che a
roma e nel frattempo vi lascio con il
video su rocket league bella non sono
più con né roberto a milano ma da milano
a milano abbiamo da milano il roberto
per cortesia allora la prima partita che
facciamo è un uno contro uno
va bene ma benissimo aspetta pippi pippi
pippi ppp perfetto
le scorte aimi pensabile non buono
psicologo allora quantico lui prendere
da 1 milione e mezzo
falk e l'ironico capito sei pronto chi
sono vieni ciccio fammi vedere di cosa è
capace 6 vivai mai come cantava chiamo
come la mer madonna che lag permessi
server asiatici per aggiungere un po di
brio ad un genio valore 36 26 offerta ma
come è possibile non l'ha lasciata
andavano vedreste fa vuole vendere in
giro minchia riggio tutti ha poi fatto
il caso nei ghetti link
va bene va bene no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no per favore c'è
successo è sempre un piacere giocare con
i miei amici ci divertiamo è un posto
tranquillo io lo chiamo io sono chip
skylark comunque presente quello dei
sentieri e sicuramente presente questa
canzone perché non avete avuto
d'infanzia ragazza loro posto di tutto
la cosa mi minuto 62 stessi anni non
conosco non con ottimi ma che cazzo non
si fosse magari ragazzi e le conosco
guardate ho segnato pure di amy estate
lo faccio pure riguardare perché sono
pure stronzo iodio
no i miei denti e meghni chip skylark no
hai presente però evidentemente la canto
io
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ra rara quando
sono solo a [ __ ] ciccio quando sono
solo sei una star senza compagnia la
voce la sento nell'aria è la voce mia mi
fa sentire un re fa e poi ciccio ma
assegnato a cancun ha creato ai miei
denti m conosco una persona si chiama
lorenzo si fa il figo ma fra poco aperte
non volevo dire altro perché non poteva
fare rima materia affanculo cazzo due
miglia e mezzo ha lavorato troppo ridere
la cosa va verso migliaia da ghiacciaio
introdotti a non bruciare bastare io ti
odio
va bene non li evito zia rosco voi non
ho segnato perché sono un po scarso ti
cioè se mi fossi nuovo lorenzo di giuro
su dio fa che un hacker il tuo canale
emette ogni giocata pago e mettono non
sa che fa con cracker non sbagliate ha
spiegato pedro
[Musica]
sbagliare lorenzo sta per detto se ne
vada è la lag che mi racconto che va
bene la ex i tuoi gol in un minuto
no no no no lo re a 144 come me la sento
e piccoli me lo sento madonna come sono
partito store
vorrei oppure dai sperando e veloce alla
mano hai vinto troppo oggi non vinci
ma perché vuoi fare la rivincita andiamo
a far da una online come faccio ora
all'alba abbiamo contro una patata
dobbiamo farcela ti sei mai ci sono
tutte mezzo punto e mezzo in mezzo e
mezzo e mezzo in mezzo tanti mezzi mette
in mezzo di mezzo i mezzi metri e mezzo
i mezzi di mezzi man's man's man's man's
man's man's man's man's man's land poche
ragazzi vi sono dei marber di mano e con
lui la grossa di toccare ciccio valenti
suoi familiari che passa si fa stava
maria fabbri vedrà gli abba sono fatto
da barilla ok ancora ancora tocca tocca
ucciso su su su giù bravo mamma mia
ragazzi soci stata qui è piaciuto mi sei
piaciuto hai mezzo ci sono invece mi
rimetto in mezzo arca demonio
occhio ma che ci fai lei usa la scusa è
ri dietro prima si sparito che si devono
farsi compagno d'attacco mi fa male
possibile
ho fatto dice 18.000 valori madonna
stato lievo cosa stavo tutta questa
colpa mia sorrido la magica 22 e zenzero
sympany ha perso scherza l'italiano
scherza come si dice in inglese giochi
jogging e voi stalking ed lo spieghiamo
perché l'ultima volta alcuni non
capitalizza vuol dire quando
l'avversario è scarso e tu lo vuoi
umiliare steve gadd perché vuol dire è
l'abbreviazione di facile è esatto
questo è in realtà poi gli avversari
stanno facendo schifo e sky momento
esatto ma porca eva terra morta nel
frutto dell'eden che ce l'ha solo lei sa
market in italy vole davvero male ma hai
tu non fai col don lorenzo le tue o che
queste mi hanno più turba non ha più
turbo
cos'ha fatto quello ricevo questa è la
faro questa è la parola
visto sta in mezzo porca vacca tira ma
guarda che però è questa la pista
innevata e devasta innevata ce la
dobbiamo fare mai forzato perché c'è la
neve per forza sono mai fatta questa sai
come non è possibile partire no ferro
scusa loro dopo alle niente no proprio
no
tocca a me la tocca a me no no no no no
no no tranquillo tranquillo tranquillo
bella ok ragazzi 500mila euro vinciamo
se vinciamo ci ha scritto lì cerchietto
500 mila euro fra amiche apposta dollari
dalla il 200 mila dollari di prezzo pur
se vinciamo stampo rai cominciamo a
quell'ora a posto ci store tu
te lo infili nella prima il culo
metterli dentro una mano e fare bene
ecco ora ancora 6 ministro insiste fatto
la finta visto che parla per la serata
sono un mostro ma tu cosa mi stavo
facendo o vado tirate tira tira no
vediamo è retromarcia inseguirla
no ho sbagliato sono altrettanto vero
che non ho fatto vengono fatti
incredibile l'ho tolta l'ho tolto farà
una tolto ma cosa 71 sono saltato e poi
l'ho tolto ma lei è sempre turbo già
tagliato io ti prego fatto impossibile
barbara bene che non entra ma sei il ma
ti amo grazie
doveva essere arrivato dal nulla dal
paradiso prendiamoci asta parti ma per
forza dobbiamo vincere davanti con 253
possiamo sia perdere che perdere vai o
no goal
no non è con no lo leggo lui valore ai
loro entrata e di retromarcia nono
mancate ritrovarci sono io
no non lo fredda
no ci fanno vinciate però si esatto sono
partita formica dovuta in mezzo ma cosa
ho visto a chi siamo incastrati tutti lì
poi è arrivato tu mamma mia che gol 4
attrarre la magia credibile ho mai
giocato e zen
ok
poi ho avuto cara tocca la male forse sì
che il ragazzo bellissimo st gol è
subito la bella seconda parola magica
per forza tecnico romano ha fatto tanta
cattiveria tesi infatti poveracci
poverini questi saranno incazzati neri
come pianista partiti fai a parlare di
quante cazzate tu scemo non vota
bravo ciccio 6 regali soglia di benji il
bel porterebbe chiamami fede game a
tavolino abbiamo vinto un tavolino ma
zitto [ __ ] team ha già fucka ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come se vi è
piaciuto molto mi piace anche adesso che
voi vedete trascrizione cosa dovresti
chiedere noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
video bel ragazzo
[Musica]